[Musique]
bonsoir à tous pour commencer un nombre
69 1430
il s'agit d'un record 69400 30
c'est le nombre de détenus dans les
prisons françaises au 1er mars 2017
soixante neuf mille quatre cent trente
détenus
cela représente plus de 98 des tenues
pour cent mille habitants
c'est à dire près de 1 détenu pour 1000
habitants
pour vous donner un ordre d'idée mille
personnes c'est probablement moins que
le nombre d'élèves du lycée que vous
avez fréquenté
c'est à dire que l'un de vos camarades
lycéens
l'un de mes camarades lycéens est
aujourd'hui en détention
alors certes 98 détenus pour cent mille
habitants
c'est cette fois moins qu'aux états unis
mais c'est aussi deux fois plus que dans
les pays d'europe du nord
à l'image des pays bas ou de la finlande
surtout 69400 30 détenus
un record cela laisse penser que le taux
de délinquance n'arrête pas d'augmenter
en france
pourtant ce n'est pas le cas
contrairement à ce que l'on entend
souvent surtout en période d'élection le
taux de délinquance n'a pas varié
beaucoup ces dernières années il est
alors logique de se poser une question
pourquoi les prisons françaises sont
toujours plus remplies la réponse est à
chercher du côté des politiques pénales
des choix sociétaux que nous avons fait
ces 20 dernières années alors je vous
propose non pas de vous demander
seulement pourquoi les prisons
françaises sont toujours plus remplie
mais quel sens
avons-nous choisi en france de donner à
la peine privative de liberté
à quoi doit servir la peine la plus
sévère de l'arsenal répressif français
à quoi doit servir la peine de prison
de toute évidence elle sert à intimider
a dissuadé les individus de violer les
règles de la société nécessaire au vivre
ensemble et le cas échéant elle sert à
punir à neutraliser c'est à dire à
mettre à l'écart les personnes jugées
dangereuses pour la sécurité de la
société pour notre sécurité
c'est d'ailleurs cette demande de
sécurité qui nous a poussés à nous
regrouper à vivre ensemble à créer
l'état et à lui confier le pouvoir de
punir mais loin d'être apaisées cette
demande de sécurité s'est intensifiée au
fil du temps la peur de l'autre s'est
démultiplié et aujourd'hui une seule
solution semble possible pour assurer
notre sécurité punir plus plus vite et
plus longtemps
par conséquent et par souci de résultat
immédiat
le législateur a multiplié les
mécanismes de neutralisation des
individus jusqu'à permettre avec la
rétention de sûreté de maintenir
enfermés pour une durée potentiellement
illimitée un individu suspecté d'être
dangereux
tous les jours en france 220 détenus
sortent de prison
si la peine doit servir à punir est
neutralisée pour être efficace à long
terme
elle ne peut donc pas servir qu'à ça la
prison est un lieu qui enferme mais la
prison est aussi un lieu d'où l'on sort
la peine de prison doit donc être un
temps utile elle doit permettre aux
condamnés de préparer son retour de là
dans la société
elle doit lui permettre de réfléchir à
ses actes pour peut-être reconstruire sa
vie
la peine doit donc punir mais elle doit
aussi éduquer normes et socialiser pour
résumer pour que la peine soit efficace
elle doit punir et re socialiser elle
doit avoir deux visages l'un tourné vers
le passé
c'est à dire vers l'acte délinquant et
la punition et l'autre tourné vers
l'avenir c'est à dire vers le retour
dans la société
la réinsertion la réinsertion
être l'horizon de la peine privative de
liberté
mais qu'en est il dans la pratique les
prisons françaises prépare-t-elle les
détenus à leur sortie
déjà qu'ils sont ces soixante neuf mille
quatre cent trente personnes détenues
pour simplifier un tiers sont des
prévenus
c'est à dire des personnes qui n'ont pas
été jugés qui n'ont pas été condamnés et
qui sont présumées innocentes
les deux autres tiers sont des condamnés
et parmi ces condamnés plus de la moitié
ne le sont que pour des atteintes aux
biens
c'est à dire des infractions de type
recel vol dégradations ils n'ont donc
commis aucune atteinte aux personnes de
type coups et blessures viol ou un
homicide
les profils des détenus sont variés
malgré cela toutes les prisons
françaises ont été pensés et construites
de la même manière elles ont été
construites pour avoir un pour atteindre
leurs objectifs de sécurité de
neutralisation et pour éviter toute
tentative d'évasion
de ce fait les bâtiments comportent de
nombreuses portes fermées à clé les
fenêtres comporte des barreaux les murs
des grillages les bâtiments comportent
aussi des caméras de surveillance des
portiques de sécurité
en raison de ce haut niveau de sécurité
un détenu coûte par an 36000 euros à
l'état et malgré ce prix élevé l'état
n'est pas en capacité de lui offrir des
conditions détention décentes
en effet les prisons sont devenues le
miroir grossissant des failles de la
société il s'y mêlent pauvreté
promiscuité violence et maladies il
existe encore de nombreux établissements
délabré des cellule de 9 mètres carrés
partagé par plusieurs codétenus des
cellules avec pour seul but des
grillages des cellules ne permettant
aucune intimité un problème amplifier
encore par la surpopulation carcérale
dont vous avez sans doute tous déjà
entendu parler une surpopulation
carcérale qui concerne les maisons
d'arrêt c'est à dire les prisons
sont enfermés les prévenus les personnes
qui sont présumées innocentes et les
détenus à de courtes peines
c'est à dire huit mois en moyenne alors
il ya la construction nouveaux
établissements mais cela ne résout rien
dans le choix sécuritaire actuelle plus
il ya de place
plus on condamne pour toutes ces raisons
les prisons françaises ne permettent pas
de jouer leur rôle de re socialisation
les conditions de détention ont plutôt
tendance à accélérer la désocialisation
des détenus alors vous allez me dire
qu'il est facile de faire un tel constat
mais qu'il est plus complexe de proposer
des solutions des solutions permettant
de trouver un équilibre entre sécurité
et liberté entre punir et réinsérer mais
il y en a et je vais vous en proposer 3
tout d'abord proposer des alternatives à
la peine de prison
il est possible de désengorger les
prisons
en développant les alternatives à la
détention et en prononçant des peines
exécutées en milieu ouvert
c'est à dire des peines exécutées dans
la société libre à l'image du travail
d'intérêt général ou du port de bracelet
électronique
ces peines permettent de sanctionner le
condamner tout en le laissant vivre dans
la société
il va ainsi subir des obligations de
travail il va être privé de sa liberté
de se déplacer mais il va garder ses
repères familiaux ou sociétaux ces
peines sont particulièrement
intéressante pour les personnes ne
présentant pas de danger pour les
personnes
en plus elle évite une incarcération et
elle évite donc aux petits délinquants
de se créer un réseau
ça évite également que la personne ne
soit transformé par la violence
carcérale justement j'en viens à ma
deuxième solution améliorer les
conditions de détention
la prison ne doit plus déshumanisé elle
ne doit plus engendré une colère des
détenus à l'encontre de la société qui
les a faits vivre dans des conditions
indignes
la prison doit être un temps utile
elle doit être un temps de mise à
l'écart durant lequel le détenu peut
penser aux conséquences de ses actes et
peut comprendre sa peine troisième
solution mieux préparer le retour dans
la société des détenus très souvent le
détenu sort de prison
l'ancien détenu sort de prison sans que
sa sortie soit préparée du coup le
retour à la société est difficile
lorsqu'il ya des aménagements de peine
qui permettent un retour en douceur dans
la société
le taux de récidive baisse de manière
significative
ce retour anticipé entouré d'obligations
permet aux détenus à l'ex détenu devrait
apprendre les règles sans contrainte
tout en étant l'objet d'un suivi par
l'état qui peut s'assurer que ce retour
dans la société se passe dans de bonnes
conditions
qui peut s'assurer que ce retour n'est
pas dangereux pour la société
cette préparation à la sortie peut aussi
se préparer dès la prison la prison
n'est pas obligé d'être toujours
coercitif elle n'est pas obligé de
toujours imposer les règles aux détenus
le niveau de sécurité peut être adapter
la prison peut être évolutive et devenir
progressivement plus éducative plus
normatives afin de permettre aux détenus
de comprendre les règles de les
assimiler pour ensuite les appliquer
seule cette possibilité elle a été
développée par les pays d'europe du nord
ces mêmes pays qui je vous le rappelle
ont un taux d'incarcération inférieur au
nôtre
il s'agit des prisons ouvertes ce sont
des prisons son mur sans barreaux ce
sont des prisons qui sont utilisés en
fin de peine
juste avant la libération pour vous
donner un ordre d'idée
ces prisons sont souvent des prisons
agricoles construite plus tôt en
campagne et elles ont la forme de petits
villages
elles sont axées sur le côté éducatif de
la peine les détenus ont le droit de se
déplacer librement durant les horaires
autorisés
la prévention des risques d'évasion
repose sur l'assimilation des règles par
les détenus
ils savent
oui ils peuvent et vous ne peuvent pas
aller ce qu'ils peuvent est ce qu'ils ne
peuvent pas faire elles ont donc un
effet ressenti en lisant
elles permettent aux détenus de vivre
dans un cadre plus paisible et surtout
dans un établissement qui est pensé pour
initier ce projet de réinsertion pour
vous donner un exemple les prisons
finlandaise permettent aux détenus de
travailler et de toucher une
rémunération de suivre des études et de
toucher une subvention
elles permettent même lorsque le détenu
obtient des autorisations spéciales
qu'il aille faire ses courses en ville
ou qu'ils prennent des jours de vacances
en échange il paie un loyer à la prison
alors il n'y a pas de mur il n'y a pas
de barreaux pour autant il n'ya pas
d'évasion
en effet les détenus ont consenti à
aller dans cette prison ouverte
ils sont volontaires et surtout ils
savent ce qu'ils risquent s'ils tentent
de s'évader un retour dans la prison
ferme et et ça il ne le veulent pas
puisqu'ils préfèrent préparer leur
sortie
malgré le caractère efficace de ces
prisons ouvertes puisqu'elles font
baisser le taux de récidive de plus de
20% et malgré leur prix une place en
prison ouverte coûte 35 % de moins
qu'une place en prison ferme et sur les
presque 200 établissements
pénitentiaires en france il n'y a que
deux prisons de ce type la prison
ouverte de casabianda en corse et la
prison village de mauzac en dordogne
je viens de vous proposer trois
solutions proposées des peines
alternatives améliorer les conditions de
détention et mieux préparer le retour à
la société des détenus il existe des
solutions
il existe des solutions permettant de
trouver l'équilibré entre punir et re
socialiser la peine peut être
individualisée la peine de prison peut
ne plus être automatique
et lorsqu'elle est prononcé la peine de
prison peut évoluer
elle peut être évolutive et
progressivement la sécurité peut laisser
place à la liberté pour que la peine
soit efficace il est temps d'ouvrir nos
esprits et il est temps d'ouvrir nos
prisons je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]